next question today is david how do you
think that these conspiracy theorists
and reactionary republicans in congress
are going to impact the next couple of
years yeah this is a really good
question
i actually have a sort of backwards
reverse approach to this which is
uh if we see i'm guessing that this
viewer is referring to people
like congresswoman marjorie taylor
greene
congresswoman lauren bober a congressman
madison
cawthorne who we saw earlier this week
just he doesn't know anything he can't
answer simple questions
i believe that whether they get
re-elected is going to
signal to us the legacy the staying
power of trumpism and what i mean by
that is
beaubert green cothorn and some of these
others
they rose to the house of
representatives in november
riding on the winds propelled by the
same
sails that defended trumpism the
trumpian cult
and they were running in the right
districts where these sort of q anon
types like marjorie taylor greene and
the wild pro gun folks like beau bird
and corn
they were able to win because of the
districts in which they ran
and sort of lifted uh by the boat of
trumpism with trump
gone now and a question we haven't heard
from trump since he left office
we'll see if we hear from him during the
next two years
whether these people get re-elected in
november of 2022
will signal whether trumpism died with
trump
and became relegated to basically
internet conspiracy theories
or whether it will have the staying
power to maintain a sort of legislative
power
and a presence in the house of
representatives if you're not familiar
with some of these people marjorie
taylor green for example she represents
georgia's 14th district
she has been a q anon supporter she
talked about
some shooting being a false flag i don't
remember if it was parkland or sandy
hook
this is a really insane person who on
january 21st drafted articles of
impeachment against joe biden
some of these folks are merely
delusional some of these folks are
hungry for power
and they see playing these trumpian
characters as the way to get that power
some of them plan to use it to griff
their way to something
beyond being members of the house uh but
this is going to be the big signal
as to whether the republican party
really eats itself
or whether it says okay yeah listen
these people were in aberration they won
because of trump but we're going to get
them out in 2022
and i don't know the answer to that i
have no advice for the republican party
what i do think is clear is if you lost
if in a two-year period between 2018 and
2020
you lose the house of representatives
you lose the senate
and you lose the white house with a
president who makes himself a one-term
president
you would think you would say it's time
to learn something from this
there's many things democrats should
learn as well i'm not saying democrats
are exempt from learning from what
happened
but if republicans learn from this then
they will figure out how to get these
people out
and to go back in the direction of you
know people like mitt romney
uh but but the truth is given the
popularity of ted cruz for example
and louis gohmert and matt gates even
before these whack jobs were elected in
november
it's not clear that there's a big
appetite for the republican party to do
that so
we'll see what happens but i think the
legacy of the republican party will be
in how it deals with and this applies to
both voters and the party apparatus
itself
how do they deal with these wacky people
that were elected in november marjorie
taylor green up there lauren bobert
madison cawthorne
i think there are others those are the
three names that come to mind right away